hello everyone and welcome to another
Armageddon game and this one is from
round seven of this year's Norway chest
it is Fabiano Corona the current leader
of the tournament against gukesh who is
doing incredibly well in the tournament
so let's check it out that their
classical game ended in a drawn after
some 34 moves it wasn't a very eventful
uh also ended fairly quickly so let's
see what happened in this one they
repeated the opening up to uh move seven
and then Fabi goes for a very very rare
move or rather an incredibly rare move
that was played against them in the
candidate tournament by Richard the
Rapport so this is what Fabi has
prepared for gokish for the faster time
format that is the Armageddon Fabi plays
E4 we have e5923 Knight to C6 and the
bishop to B5 going for the Rue Lopez as
they did in the uh classical game with
Knight to F6 the Berlin defense D3
Bishop to C5 and now Bishop captures in
C6 the captors might beat the D2 with
Bishop to E6 and now in their classical
game five we just castled here this is
the main move in this this line but here
we have Pawn to H3 the move are upward
played against Fabi in the candidates
tournament so Knights the D7 you need to
defend the E5 Pawn uh and uh in case
some of you are wondering why not just
capture the pawn right away well there's
always this queen to D for move I'm sure
you guys already know this but just in
case uh so like I said H3 Knight to D7
guarding the E5 pawn and Knight the B3
now attacking the bishop and in that
game in the Kansas that we mentioned
Fabi versus Rapport or rapper versus
Fabi fabul played Bishop to B6 but here
we have Bishop back to E7 by gookish uh
Knight to A5 going after the B5 pawn and
there is one gamer Bishop the B4 check
was played was played between Robin's
Winkles and uh
uh and uh uh sorry let me just check
real quickly I think it was yeah it was
a max volume at them uh between uh these
two gentlemen uh it was played uh in
2016 and uh uh environmental was able to
win that game but here we have Queen to
C8 and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new game uh so here
upon the B3 you want to develop the
bishop also the Knight is coming to C4
at some point then maybe it's the E3
then maybe the F5 and so on so the
Knight is a bit weird on A5 but not for
long uh both players Castle here castles
castles and now Pawn to C5 uh very very
nicely done uh we have uh Ponte A4 and
now Pawn to B6 chasing away the Knight
Knight the C4 and now Pawn to F6 uh we
have Knights the H4 I'm going for the F5
square and Rook to d8 a nicely aligning
The Rook with the queen so far it
develops at Queen to F3 and Knight to B8
now now the Knight is coming to C6 also
one of the reasons why I really wanted
to advance this double C pawn queen to
G3 and now Knight the C6 we have Pawn to
F4 5B manages to get this Central
breakthrough in uh but now Knight the D4
putting pressure on the C2 Pawn we have
rook df2 and now King the h8 not
allowing the king to remain on the same
file as the queen uh F captures an E5
with Bishop captures on C4 first and now
B captures on C4 if you're wondering why
not grab another Pawn while you're at it
because it comes with Tempo you are
threatening Chuck mate well the problem
is then you after let's say captures and
captures then after the Knight moves the
bishop can come to D for the best we can
come to E5 and it doesn't look like
you've achieved all that much and also
you can uh forcefully play this with
nice day to check also The Rook on A1
would hang uh that's only you know some
of the problems so beat captures and C4
right away by Fabi F captures an E5 and
now Knights the F5 putting pressure on
the bishop on the Knight and of course
threatening Checkmate here so Bishop F6
stopping that and now Bishop to G5
removing the defender of of Checkmate
Bishop captures and G5 Queen captors and
now Queen to D7 now the queen is
defending against Checkmate uh Rook 8 to
F1 Fabi doubles up on the f file and now
Rook to f8 we have King to H2 and now
Knight the E6 attacking fabi's queen
queen back to G3 and now Knight to F4 we
have Queen to G4 and now a rook to F6
preparing to bring the other Rook into
the game uh Knight the E3 offering a
queen trade but of course Luke is not
interested he likes his active position
Queen to D4 Knight to F5 again attacking
the queen and queen back to D7 gookish
happily repeats because a draw in
Armageddon equals a win we have Pawn to
G3 Fabi has to look for ways the uh you
know create some imbalances in the
position Knight the E6 and now Knight
the E3 offering the trade of Rooks and
the goopers is all right but on my terms
Rook 8 fate Rook captures and F6 with
Rook captures and F6 and all the Rooks
come off the board captures and captures
and now upon the age for at least the
Fabi found a way to continue pushing
with Queen to F7 and now King to G2
at night the D5 although looks like a
very nice move after C6 there's really
no good Square for this Knight you have
to go back uh so uh King to G2 now Fabi
wants to bring his King all the way to
the queen side so he can start advancing
those King side pawns uh without
compromising the safety of his King so
here Pawn to C6 King to F2 and now Queen
to G8 offering a queen trade Fabi
declines now uh Queen to F7 and now Pawn
to H5 hoping to get Pawn to H6 in so
Google stops this but now the H6 spawn
is also a Target so Queen to G4
preparing Knight to F5 to go after the
Pawn King the H7 and knights the F5 we
have Knights the G7 and here Fabi traded
the knights Knight captures and G7 even
there was uh Merit in in maybe at least
considering Knights to D6 because you
take away all of these squares from the
black queen and you don't really want to
allow the queen to infiltrate via Queen
to G6 and then if Queen captures an H5
okay you temporarily give up a pawn but
look at this cap captors to ignite the
C8 now now you will win some queen size
pawns let's say six Knight captures on
B6 Knight to G7 and now Knights the D7
going after the F6 pawn and the C5 Pawn
you're gonna win another one probably
black will defend the F6 pawn and now
this uh Europe opponent King Pawn and
Knight end game you should be winning
this without much trouble so instead
Knight captures and G7 was played we
have Queen captures and G7 and now again
Queen F5 check with King date shape uh
Fabi prefers to play the Queen uh and
Pawn in the game instead of the Knight
and pawn end game Queen to C8 checking
to H7 and he grabs the C6 Pawn so Queen
captures on C6 Queen to E7 and queen to
King to F3 now we have King to G7 Queen
to C8 and now Queen to F7 Luke is just
waiting to see what Fabi will do and
Fabi finds a way to move forward King to
G4 also defends the H5 Pawn which is
very nice King to H7 now comes King the
H4 sidestepping any and all shot X King
to G7 and now King to G for repeating
once but not twice now Queen to fight
with check uh the real way to play this
and this is winning for Fabi is Queen
the C6 the point is that whatever black
plays and you don't really care about uh
any checks then uh you can just go up
the board but uh Queen t7 for example
Queen to D5 will come and then once you
repeat or queen to G7 check doesn't
really matter uh just uh King to F5 and
now again if you repeat Queen to G5 King
just goes to E6 and then you will start
gobbling up all the pawns and if Queen
to E7 you will just play Queen to E6
you've won all the important squares and
now you win the game uh but Fabi uh
incredibly low on time and in Armageddon
yes you do get increment but only after
move 40 and you only get one second
increment per move so it's basically
enough to make them will hit the clock
and then instantly instantly instantly
it's very exhausting so Queen to F5 with
check King to G7 now comes King to F3 uh
Fabi will first hide his King all the
way to the queen inside before
committing to something else and it also
doesn't require him to waste a lot of
time so Queen 8 King Day 3 Queen F7 G
for now Queen 38 King 32 Queen F7 and
queen to C8 now queen t7 king to C3
Queen to F7 and Kingdom B3 and the wild
king will be saved here Queen t7 and now
Queen to F5 now Fabi is confident that
he will be able to push this for a win
Queen the E8 King the A3 even and now
Pawn to A5 we have kicked back to B3 uh
Queen to F7 and queen to C8 we have
queen t7 queen to C6 and now Queen to d8
we have Queen to E6 Fabi winning a lot
of important squares here but now Queen
to D4 and here Lucas finds a an
incredible way of how to save the game
if Fabi doesn't take his chance at
actually winning so Queen E7 check King
to G8 and here Fabi makes an incredible
mistake especially for for Fabi I mean
who is a human calculating machine he
just plays Queen captures on F6 and it's
uh not a I mean of course he was he had
a second on the clock and
he has to continue making moves in order
not to lose some time but in order to
win this uh you have to play Queen to E8
check and then you will pick up the F6
Pawn but it will be with tempo for
example King to G7 Queen to G6 uh check
doesn't really matter where the King
goes uh as the F6 Pawn will fall with
check and then you continue with a win
but even if Bobby knew this he probably
wouldn't be able to win because the win
is very elusive Queen captures on F6 was
played uh now comes Queen to A1 and here
gookish has uh either a Perpetual or a
Checkmate it's a quite beautiful queen
to G6 check King to f8 Queen captures on
H6 with check and now King to G8 Lucas
again uh runs into runs into a losing
position the way to win this was King to
F7 now the point is after a few checks
are given King day seven Queen to G7
check doesn't really matter King to d8
you will either continue checking the
black king and the Black Wing King will
just go uh back and forth or you will
advance the pawn finally and then Queen
to B1 is a draw it's a draw because if
you go to C3 Queen to B4 is Checkmate so
you have to go to A3 and then it's just
a queen A1 to B1 to A1 and you continue
checking the white king this is now a
draw however I think the G8 was played
now Fabi is once again winning Queen the
G6 with checking the h8 and now Queen to
F6 with check King to G8 and now Queen
to G5 uh again Fabi doesn't find the the
real idea but the real idea is so so
elusive that it's incredibly difficult
to figure out how to actually play it uh
even if you know you had all the time in
the world how would you win this
position feel free to pause the video
don't try to find a specific move try to
find the idea of how this game should be
won so I have at it while I give you a
couple of seconds
uh for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is basically something uh well any moves
any move order that will allow your
queen to get to the B5 Square you have
to bring your queen to B5 and then you
are winning uh for example Queen D6
checking to f8 uh Queen to C8 with the
check doesn't really matter where the
King goes King G7 Queen to D7 with the
check now you've nicely connected to
check with the B5 square and the ones
the king makes any move Queen to B5 and
now you are winning point is that now
after Queen to B1 check you don't have
to worry about King to C3 as the queen
before will not be Checkmate like we've
shown in the other line and here you
don't have checks if this you go here no
more checks and if Queen T one check you
go to B2 again no more checks so that's
how you win this now you just up too
many pawns and of course completely
winning however Queen the G5 check was
played King to h8 and here Fabi played
Queen to d8 with check and his position
is still winning yeah if he can
re-maneuver his Queen Queen over to B5
the problem is he took more than a
second the full play Queen to the eight
and hit the clock and it was in this
position and move 71 that Fabiano
Cortana lost on time and that means that
gukesh wins uh wins this encounter so a
brilliant stuff uh gookish neutralized
Fabi in the in the classical section
without uh without any problems and here
in Armageddon a Fabi just wasted too
much time and then in the end I mean
okay he did get the increment but you
have one second increment and if you're
down to one second on the clock uh I
mean that's hard to play even uh online
you know when you're just pre-moving I
mean one second is not a lot but you
know actually physically moving it uh
hitting the clock and uh you know just
watching the board I mean it will take
you more than one second you have to
have like a
um like the mindset of being in shock to
be able to to play uh something like
this so it wasn't possible here and
bookish uh just wins this very nicely uh
sure uh very nicely done by him if you
guys are interested here are the uh the
uh uh Encounters of Fabi lost to Google
in Armageddon and Wesley defeated
another waking classical uh Hikaru
defeated chakra Armageddon a Magnus
defeated in Armageddon we've seen both
of the games uh and Anish defeated tari
in classical chess so still no no luck
for for tari and these are the standings
of the tournament Fabiano still in first
place with 14 and a half in Hikaru in
second place with 12 and a half and we
might be getting uh a super clash in the
tournament because
um Fabi and Hikaru are playing in the
final round so if if this Remains the uh
you know the points 14 and a half twelve
and half uh Hikaru will have an
opportunity to beat Fabi in the final
round in the classical uh chess uh to
overtake him uh in the win win the
tournament then Wesley with ten and a
half Ag bookish and danish with ten
alireza with nine and a half magnets
with nine uh with nine under back with
six and 30 with 3 and the incredible
Magnus again won all of his games unless
the one again with Fabi it's just that
he won all of them with Armageddon so
Magnus did not win a single game here in
classical and that's why he is in uh
Seventh Place uh currently and here are
the live ratings if you guys are
interested uh not a lot it's happening
with Aviano still and number one as he
was in number two as it was in the
previous one Magnus losing a lot of
rating points because he is he's only
getting draws here uh Hikaru up up on
plus eight Anish plus three a Wesley
plus four uh mvl minus four bootcash
plus three and Wei ye playing some other
tournament also on plus six so not a lot
happening but you know there is
something happening that's yeah that's
the game and a little bit of extra info
uh from round seven of this year's
Norway chess hope you guys enjoyed it if
you have uh any other games that you
would like me to show use hashtag
suggestion or maybe from some other
tournaments as the days the rest day we
do have some time to catch up so you
know do use hashtag suggestion I always
look at the uh all of your suggestions
after I once again really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Mikhail
Sakari as David gasparian Brandon fukuda
Ricky Johnson and uh
Sonic for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful tournament
until it finishes uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day